i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
this is a very sort of surprising way to
start today's show but there is now
speculation that donald trump is in
washington dc
and may be getting arrested or indicted
imminently now it is speculative but the
speculation is based on a previously
unannounced
seemingly last-minute trip that donald
trump made to washington dc last night
newsweek reporting donald trump's
surprise visit to washington d.c sparks
arrest speculation trump made a
surprised and unannounced visit to dc
sunday prompting speculation and rumors
about the reason for his trip the video
of trump arriving at dulles airport in
virginia an airport frequently used by
those heading to the capitol was posted
online by freelance reporter andrew
lydon trump can be seen getting out of a
plane heading into a vehicle trump
appears to be wearing golf shoes and a
white polo top now
we're getting into details that seem so
trivial but there have already been
counterpoints that it appears to be a
golf uh his golf shoes but those are not
actually shoes trump wears to golf and
thus the idea is he is not just showing
up to golf or necessarily coming from
the golf course uh but trump does stay
at his golf courses when he fl travels
around if there's one available
and the motorcade then uh is believed to
have gone in the direction of one of
trump's golf courses now there is video
of what took place and there are a
number of very strange things in the
video we're going to play it see if you
can spot some of them then i'll mention
a couple of things that i notice and
that others have noticed as well
uh we see donald trump coming off the
plane holding something
not totally clear what he is holding
and getting into a vehicle
is making its way off and then this is
at 6 31 pm
and then they drive away
one of the really really strange things
that was pointed out
is that it sort of looks like trump is
carrying a bottle of ketchup
a bottle of ketchup
which is an extraordinarily strange
thing for a president a former president
to be carrying
but it might be something else could be
a maga hat folded up or who knows what
it is so there's a couple of different
things going on here first of all
do we really know why he's in dc we
don't
do we know that it is an unexpected and
unplanned trip up until the last moment
we do because there generally is uh
awareness of the
soon to be whereabouts of the former
president
one explanation would be some kind of
medical issue certainly a possibility a
second possibility
he's he's back to be reinstated as
president of the united states
one i believe is likely but there are
already the sort of q people and
conspiracy people that are speculating
along these lines already and number
three is that it has something to do
with the federal investigation against
him um for
he's in there in the city for meetings
that were previously undisclosed based
on who knows what is going on okay fine
um this is strange there are a number of
strange things here for people who
understand sort of protocol and the
amount of information that is known
ahead of time about where donald trump
plans to be this is certainly unusual
now for those who are continuing to have
this idea of the perp walk the perp walk
that at some point may happen if donald
trump is indicted i don't think it makes
sense to hold our breaths for that as
i've said before every indication that
if indeed donald trump is going to be
indicted that there is going to be a
sort of coordinated handoff involving
secret service and that there is not
going to be the perp walk that many of
us
admittedly would love to see of donald
trump at some point in time but no
shortage of the conspiracy people
immediately jumping to he is back to be
declared president by i don't know the
newly anointed king charles iii or who
the hell knows what that is not what
donald trump is in washington dc for
you now know everything that is known to
us as of this moment and by the time
today's episode goes live by the time
this clip gets up on youtube and
facebook and elsewhere since it takes a
couple of hours for us to turn the show
around there may be more known and we
will then follow up about it i have some
amazing video
from uh radical republican congresswoman
lauren bobert's recent debate
as some of you may know
there is a 2022 midterm election just
around the corner now about seven weeks
away
and some of the main debates are
starting we are following very closely
will john fetterman and mehmet oz debate
will herschel walker finally agree to
debate rafael warnock and we are
following all of these lauren beaubert
participated in a debate against her
opponent adam frisch
and she seemed to glitch very very badly
i don't know how many of you remember
when marco rubio during a republican
primary debate in 2016 repeated the same
answer multiple times almost like a
glitchy robot i don't know how many of
you remember
kelly lefler with her radical liberal
raphael warnock repeated repeated line
during her debates with raphael warnock
lauren beaubert answering
close to a dozen questions by talking
about nancy pelosi
and her con game it is bizarre
the bobert bot
glitching badly check this out candidate
bobert you have three minutes for that
nancy pelosi is running a con game in
washington dc by the way nancy pelosi is
not lauren bobert's opponent in case in
case you thought maybe that's why she
kept talking about pelosi nancy's con
game works like this fire nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi's i'm adam fresh i'm not
nancy pelosi i'm adam frisch i'm not
nancy pelosi
pelosi uh plays and it's with pelosi's
con game the pelosi pushes this
but she will put a 2
000 page bill
on our desks at midnight nancy pelosi's
con game playing nancy's con game to do
it yeah dc to play nancy pelosi's con
game i it makes me terribly sad when
nancy pelosi uses
more inflation more borrowing from china
and pelosi knows it pelosi's
con games this was um a blank check and
okay um
i'm adam frisch i'm not nancy pelosi
there was no interest and nancy pelosi
is running a con game under pelosi
democrats are told the pelosi con game
in aspen and just like pelosi budget
committee and nancy pelosi will not it's
not time to help nancy pelosi it is time
to fire nancy pelosi this election say
no to liberal extremists and their army
of irs agents
i'm adam fresh i'm not nancy pelosi i'm
adam frisch i'm not nancy pelosi okay
um
they have quite literally nothing to
offer there is nothing to offer there
and if you live in uh lauren beaubert's
district in colorado it's a very red
district i understand that in bobert um
oh no actually this may be a district
that was redrawn so in any case the
previously beau bert's district was was
a very red district
fine you don't like nancy pelosi but
don't you as a republican in her
district
bobert's district still want to hear
some vision of what bobert will do even
if it's things that i don't agree with
don't their own voters want to hear
here are the types of regulations i'm
going to try to get cut here's how i
would change the tax code here's uh here
are the types of projects i would
support in order to bring dollars into
this district like it seems weird that
even the voters in colorado are so
concerned with nancy pelosi in this way
that this would be an effective campaign
strategy but the saddest thing about it
is this stuff can probably work okay in
these highly weaponized electorates when
when you have such a highly weaponized
constituency as lauren bobert does
where they don't even really understand
the types of things lauren bobert could
be advocating for for them
they have become propagandized to the
point where her own voters believe the
role of someone like bobert whoever is
their member of congress
is to do things like
fight the pelosi con job
we have such a lack of education and
understanding of what these elected
officials can even do for us that there
was a time where the way that these
debates would go would be it would be a
focus on the district and sure yeah i
mean listen congress has a investigative
role when it comes to whether to bring
articles of impeachment and congress has
an oversight role of court they choose
the speaker of the house yes but there
was a time when what voters wanted to
hear was
their candidates understanding of their
district not what's going on in nancy
pelosi san francisco or in washington dc
understand what's going on in our
district hey you know what in our
district we have a dozen bridges that
are rated
low whatever high risk of uh possible
failure
here are the three ways in which i'm
going to take care of those bridges in
our district so that all of your
commutes to work are safer so that we
don't risk huge traffic
interruptions when these br and loss of
life we prevent loss of life when you
and your kids are driving over this is
just an example but there was a time
where that was the approach and the
candidates would debate about well i
would like to better our infrastructure
this way
versus the other candidate wants to
better our infrastructure that way i'm
talking 30 years ago at least okay but
that's the way it used to be
it's now oh nancy pelosi's con job and
this is something they just they've
tried before with this stuff it
fortunately failed for kelly lefler but
remember when kelly lefler pulled this
or tried to pull it against raphael
warnock during that special election in
2021
the democrats want to fundamentally
change america and the agent of change
is my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock my opponent radical liberal
raphael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock radical liberal rafael warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock radical
liberal raphael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock is a socialist radical
liberal rafael warnock radical liberal
rafael warnock radical liberal rafael
warnock radical liberal rafia warnock
radical liberal rafael warnock anyway it
goes on from there now fortunately in
that special election in georgia it
didn't work and there were some special
dynamics including quite frankly that
trump and people around him were saying
it was all rigged anyway in georgia in
november and that probably dissuaded a
lot of republicans from even going out
to vote on january 5th in that special
election because listen even their dear
orange leader told them it's all rigged
your vote essentially doesn't matter so
a lot of special things went on there
and so it didn't work for leffler but
this is not a new thing and it has
succeeded for them to some degree
because their constituents accept it
they have come to
embrace a complete lack of policy
discussion
in exchange accepting things like well
warnock's a socialist and nancy pelosi's
running a con job let's see how it works
out for them in november
next week on 9 19 september 19 we will
be doing our next one day membership
special folding in
many new members into the ranks of
membership i hope
if you've been thinking
i would get a membership but it's got to
be a good deal get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then next monday 9
19 you'll get an email from us bright
and early in the morning telling you how
to take advantage of this great
membership discount
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to
aura.com pacman you will get aura free
for 14 days which you can use to do
things like see if your passwords have
been leaked the link is down below
former democratic senator al franken
appeared on cnn alongside republican
strategist alice stewart to talk about
the supreme court's decision to overturn
roe v wade in the political orientation
of the court and i have not seen
anything like this in a very long time
al franken turned alice stewart into a
sputtering mess over the issue of
republicans holding up nominations
including that of merrick garland and it
is it's truly a pleasure to watch and
you know one of the things we've been
talking about on the show is democrats
need to be on the offensive gavin
newsome said democrats need to be
ruthless and i completely agree
we need more like this because when you
actually don't allow them to squirm away
from direct questions like
when else was this strategy used to deny
nominees a hearing
other than for merrick garland
alice stewart completely implodes this
is so well done take a look a week
before the election
that
destroyed the legitimacy of the court
alice what do you think did chief
justice roberts sort of
i mean he sort of
ignored some of what al is talking about
there and that there is i mean
a tremendous amount of controversy
as to how this court got tilted in the
direction of the far right just to
throw a little accuracy and some of what
what al said there look the the merrick
garland
was held up because we had a divided
government we had a democrat in the
white house and we had republicans in
control of that's not what was that's
not what mcconnell said
but
but that's the way
historically this has been when you're
in close to an election year and you
have divided government out of the way
it's being historically done yes and
when you when you have divided
government there typically is uh now
you'll actually see the moment she
starts sputtering inclination to tell me
when this happened before
when you
went close to another
when you're well merrick garland is
certainly one when there's a divided
government no before
they're moving they're not moving
forward tell me when this happened
before uh al i'm telling you this is
what the
uh
tell me what happened before i i can't
this is what happened historically tell
me when it happened before look this is
the way that the republicans where uh
like i can't give you an exact example
of when this happens
because it hadn't happened before
look
the basis for not appointing him was
because of that specific reason but no
it wasn't and mcconnell's explicitly
said that it was the quote biden rule
and he quoted a little piece of of a
speech that biden had given
in june
of 80
and
he did biden said they wouldn't take up
if they weren't consulted and if and
this was about someone resigning in june
after a term of the court which is very
different than someone dying
scalia died in february
and you saw
you guys if you can find the tape you
can find uh lindsey graham saying
i
keep the tape
we will not take up
a judge of if someone dies a ju
a nominee if someone dies an election
year in the next
in the next election
this is total hypocrisy and you actually
i i'm surprised that you're claiming
this and you can't come up with an
example because there is none
to get back to the point of the cause no
but this is the no
this is the point that's exactly right
we're talking about kamala harris and
her calling kamala the current uh
supreme court justices activist justices
because she doesn't like the outcome of
their ruling and
when they're made their decision yeah
and of course the point here is how did
this court even become what it is um i
think that to some degree
uh this is what democrats need to do
every time republicans lie
call them out shame them continue to
expose that they are lying now why was
that why did this even happen you have
to understand right
it's because jim acosta allowed it to
happen
in many other settings
the anchor or the interviewer will will
prevent this from happening either
uh for reasons of time and formatting or
because they want to bail out one side
jim acosta at any point could have
jumped in and saved alice stewart she
didn't deserve to be saved and it's a
good thing that jim acosta didn't she
was lying and the other person she's
arguing against called her out for her
lies and it was silly to think
that you were going to be able to get
away with that with someone like al
franken al franken identified the silly
game and he called it out
now uh this is representative of a
bigger issue with the republican party
right now
they have zero integrity in politics
if there is no precedent or a rule that
says you can't do something they will do
it and then they will say that's the
precedent i mean think of the
i want to stop short of calling it evil
genius because it's it's these things
aren't really that smart they work
because the system tolerates them and
the people tolerate them and maybe maybe
we shouldn't but
the the idea here is
she says
okay well we did this thing with merrick
garland and al franken says but what's
the precedent for that and she says well
it happened with garland right no but
what's the precedent at that point what
was the precedent
we did it with garland no but that
garland can't be the precedent for
garland it's all so stupid and it's such
a base and fundamentally vapid
uh uh
sort of framing of the debate
but when they're allowed to get away
with it of course they're going to
continue doing it and you know to go
back to the al franken thing we've
talked about this before al franken did
engage in a very distasteful joke you
know this photograph uh that that led to
his eventual resignation from the from
the senate um i i do think
democrats were a little quick in order
to show their
lack of hypocrisy in demanding that
franken resign when compared to so many
other things that have happened for
which no one has resigned
it was so
minor
and we've talked to democrats who say
yeah it was it was actually a little bit
uh jumping the gun on demanding frank
and resign just to show how
non-hypocritical we are
uh franken is really good at this and
absolutely humiliating there for alice
stewart also humiliating by the way
new interview
on the anniversary of 9 11 the 21st
anniversary of 9 11 which was over the
weekend
republican
senate nominee in georgia herschel
walker appeared on fox news's program
with maria bartoromo
and he tried to make a statement about
the 21st anniversary of 911
and it was completely unintelligible and
confusing very shaky
the entire interview was very shaky he
is now winning in more polls walker is
now ahead of warnock in georgia and look
at how he can't even make sense of
anything
well you know you got to pay tribute to
uh the 9 11 victims uh you know but also
you saw america come together you saw
america come together because this
country was uh you know it was uh on the
war with uh
a country that didn't believe in us and
right what
this country was on the war against a
country that didn't believe in us and
then the country came together
does he think that
the iraq war was related to 911 even
though that's been widely debunked for
decades
does he think that the war
was with a different country it's not
clear what he's talking about now we
have uh leaders in washington like joe
biden doing venomous speeches right that
doesn't believe in american people
right so walker continuing to really
struggle to make any sense
walker at one point raised the great
maya angelou
and um
try to
use language that certainly would make
maya angelou
uh
up in the heavens roll her eyes i'm sure
for this country i'm fighting for
georgia because if we give up that seat
and i know maya angelou said it when you
see what when somebody tells you who
they are believe them right now since
raphael went up been in office we got
higher taxes we got higher gas prices we
got the economy has gone is is terrible
right we have almost full employment
we have gas prices seeing one of their
fastest declines in a long time the gas
price increase had nothing to do with
warnock the gas price decrease has
nothing to do with warnock um and then
as far as taxes going up there just
there has not been uh tax reform where
quote taxes have gone up in the in the
vague and overarching way that herschel
walker is talking about just none of it
makes sense during the same interview
walker saying 70 of drugs go through
atlanta georgia tell me about the issues
and what needs to be done regarding the
border and crime
well one of the things that people don't
know georgia is not a border state but
seven percent of the drugs coming into
this country goes through atlanta
georgia and that's something that my
opponent don't want to address well he's
not addressing it because there's no
evidence that it's true it's really
unclear what walker means by 70 of drugs
coming into this country go through
atlanta i researched it under any of its
possible meanings i was unable to verify
that claim does he mean that the 70 of
drugs are coming through the atlanta
airport which is a major airport
does he mean that 70 of the drugs are
being driven through atlanta georgia on
the roads
by no
possible definition was i able to verify
that and then lastly
walker with
i think that this is a transphobic
statement but it's not even really clear
that's something that my opponent don't
want to address you don't want to
address the border have you noticed that
it seemed like everyone on the left
don't want to address the problem this
economy crime they don't want to address
they don't address men and women in
sports they don't want to address they
even talking about regrowth to talk
about whether a man can get pregnant
that's not important right yeah
uh he really has a way with words but i
don't know what the hell he's talking
about and he is
increasingly winning
winning his race can you believe that if
we look at the latest polling data the
last three polls
have walker ahead
the last three polls have walker ahead
this is a guy who should have zero
percent support
but our electorate
and particularly the electorates of
states like georgia to some degree
particularly among republicans in
georgia
horrifying weaponized propagandized
individuals
it's scary stuff extraordinarily scary
stuff
john bolton and michael cohen both
speculated
that donald trump likely moved at least
some of the documents the fbi wanted to
a different golf club
and it is now increasingly looking like
that may well be the case
did trump transfer documents to
bedminster that's another one of his
golf clubs ex-fbi official floats the
theory
peter strzok
had a very interesting tweet thread
over the weekend where he said better
check bedminster
on may 6 nara emails trump to say
material is missing and maybe at
mar-a-lago that we know this is part of
what ultimately led to the raid
on may 9th trump gets on a private plane
from palm beach to met bedminster on
video several boxes are seen loaded onto
the plane that is indeed true you see in
this picture there are boxes being
loaded onto the plane okay but we don't
boxes or boxes there could be you know
just sudafed in there could be anything
peter strzok goes on to say does the
type and brand of box look familiar
well yeah i mean it does look like the
exact type of box that is pictured in
the image of donald trump's office
where the documents were found
great visual says peter strzok though
number one might be two stacked boxes
meaning nine not eight boxes good
example of harm to national security
from waiting to use mar-a-lago
classified documents id and interview
these folks compare their fingerprints
to those on the seas documents and empty
folders
and
certainly when you look at this video
you do see
a lot of boxes that look identical to
the ones that were carried out that were
photographed in trump's office being
carried onto the plane that is
absolutely true now it is speculative
this is a speculative case
but it makes perfect sense and remember
trump's own former national security
adviser michael uh michael bull
it would be like trump to have michael
bolton as is uh i i make what happened
there is
michael cohen and john bolton i it's a
portmento michael bolton the singer
um john bolton trump's former national
security adviser said he probably moved
documents elsewhere
michael cohen who knows trump well
said he probably has documents elsewhere
these are likely not all the documents
then we find empty folders marked top
secret
and of course trump didn't take empty
folders at some point they had something
in them and where the documents are
remains a question
we don't know for sure but as we build
up a picture of what took place we see
that the likeliest scenario the simplest
explanation
is that there are documents elsewhere
somewhere and now it's a matter of
finding them we'll have the clip i
played of the boxes being loaded if
you're just listening today we'll have
that clip on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman's show if you
want to take a look for yourself
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
well this you have to see to believe or
maybe not donald trump wants you and me
taxpayers to pay for his bogus special
master that never should have even been
granted so let's back up and i'll tell
you what's going on
business insider headline trump wants to
split the cost of the special master
with the government
but the doj wants him to pay for it
a judge granted trump's request for a
special master but the doj has appealed
the decision now remember judge eileen
cannon granted trump's request for a
special master a special master would
take control of all the documents seized
from trump's mar-a-lago would review
them and would see are there documents
here that shouldn't be part of the fbi
investigation because they are in some
way privileged are there documents here
that shouldn't be part of the
investigation maybe because they contain
medical information or whatever the case
may be
that granting of a special master has
been found by legal experts who have
weighed in to be absolutely absurd and
raises major questions about judge
eileen cannon fine but then we get to
the question of who's going to pay for
this a new court filing shows the two
sides disagree
over who should pay for the special
master the government said trump as the
party requesting the special master
should bear the cost but trump wants the
government to split it with him
even though the doj does not agree
the filing also outlined disagreements
between the government and trump's legal
team regarding how the entire special
master process would unfold no surprise
there trump's team proposed to split
evenly the professional fees and
expenses of the special master and any
professionals support staff and expert
consultants engaged at the masters
request but the justice department has
already started reviewing the c's
materials doesn't want a special master
appointed and disagreed
the government's position is that as the
party requesting the special master
plaintiff should bear the additional
expense of the special master's work
um
this actually could be so hypothetical
if judge eileen cannon
is coming around to the fact that her
decision to grant the special master was
the wrong decision if she's coming
around to that
this could be a way to get out because
we know trump doesn't pay for stuff and
the decision could be made
uh you pay for all of it or there's no
special master
that would be one thing that to look at
that would be interesting but the whole
premise of trump's argument
uh and the judge ruling with him
is that his documents must be protected
and sorted through
the government doesn't have such a
concern if the government believes that
they were authorized to obtain the
documents that everything was done on
the up and up all of those things and
and uh indeed remember that classified
and top secret documents
those aren't trump's documents those are
government documents if trump wants to
make the case they are his documents and
they shouldn't be released in all these
different things
it should be him it should be he
who actually ends up paying for it and
we don't know if that's actually the
direction it's going to go it doesn't
make sense that trump gets to dictate
to the government
what of its own documents because
remember as william barr has said this
um who else has said so many republicans
have now said these aren't trump's
documents these are government documents
these are the people's documents for
lack of a better term it doesn't make
sense that trump gets to tell the
government what they need to do with
their own documents and then they also
pay for that it is trump who has to get
to do that he wants the special master
he should have to pay for it it doesn't
make sense to keep deferring to him in
this way now what's the strategy
the strategy is just a delay
that's the strategy and it's a
well-known legal strategy
you often
it applies
often in criminal trials where most
criminal defense attorneys will tell you
the longer we can delay the better for
everybody number one and this is i sort
of say this tongue-in-cheek but also not
the more motions to delay that a lawyer
can file and succeed with
uh the more the lawyer gets to bill all
else being equal and continue extending
extending extending and listen at the
end of the day yeah lawyers want to make
money oh the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah sometimes people want
to make money okay but that's not to
suggest lawyers would unethically do
that there's also the legal explanation
which the lawyers have told me which is
the longer you can delay a criminal case
witnesses might die
witnesses recollection becomes less
accurate
documents might be lost evidence might
be misplaced and it generally speaking
favors defendants to delay delay delay
in criminal trials laws might change
this applies more to like white collar
and even though generally speaking
the way you were prosecuted is based on
what the law was at the time it's still
not going to hurt you if the law changes
in a way that is favorable all these
different things can happen so
that's the strategy here delay as much
as possible period and this is it's like
a kid trying to delay bedtime well you
know i need to use the bathroom and i'm
getting thirsty and oh i don't know i
need to check what's my lunch tomorrow
and now i'm hungry and then oh well i
gotta brush my teeth again it's the same
type of thing and now trump wants you to
pay for it and hopefully that is
rejected let's talk a little bit about
william barr
william barr was the attorney general at
the end of donald trump's failed
presidential term
and william barr has basically turned on
trump but would probably still vote for
him over a democrat i know think think
that through uh but william barr has now
said listen all of this stuff about
privilege doesn't make sense trump
having documents at a country club
doesn't make sense none of it makes
sense and now it does appear as though
trump has fully turned on william barr
as well
sort of a deranged open mic night
feel at bedminster over the weekend
that's one of donald trump's golf clubs
and in what is just an absolutely
terrible terrible attempt at stand-up
comedy uh trump went after bill barr
basically by calling him fat saying all
he wanted to do was eat check this out
and i apologize for the poor audio
[Music]
one of quality steps that we have these
weak stupid people
against attorney generals that don't
know how to do their job
like real far all we want to do
[Music]
yeah what's crazier the things that
trump says like my attorney general was
fat
even though by the way trump doesn't
exactly look like he's missed too many
meals
or the fact that the cult members laugh
as if this stuff were funny as if this
stuff were fun both are kind of weird
um another uh clip this also i believe
this is also from bedminster but in a
different room or something
here trump is already suggesting that
sarah huckabee sanders who's running for
governor of arkansas and yes she's the
daughter of former arkansas governor
mike huckabee trump already is floating
that sarah huckabee sanders is going to
have the election stolen from her due to
this uh ubiquitous and ever-present
fraud i bought a trump tie can you
believe that
right
and i said i love this guy
i love this guy but mike has been a
friend of mine from the beginning and
his daughter as you know
i give janet the credit
i give you the credit but and they're
both here by the way two incredible
people but his daughter uh is just an
exceptional person yeah an exceptional
person and when you see what they have
right now feeding us the information and
then you compare that with sarah
it's uh it's not even believable she was
so incredible and she took abuse and she
gave it back when necessary
but she took tremendous abuse and they
were nasty right from day one but there
was nobody ever like her now she's going
to be well i mean we don't want to talk
there still is an election in november
like right you know so she still has to
win it they say pretty routine but
there's nothing routine in politics mike
you know maybe those votes don't come in
maybe they find a couple of million
votes like they did with us
there'll be a big dump at 302 in the
morning
in the state of arkansas more dumps
the votes will be found and she will
have lost by 100 votes
now i mean it's not gonna happen but she
uh but she still does have an election
so we have to remember that but she's an
incredible person yeah now trump is
right it does seem like it's that george
the arkansas gubernatorial seems like
it's mostly going to be a formality
doesn't look like a democrat's going to
take that one but this is the constant
undermining of confidence in our
election systems and there's nothing
concerning happening in arkansas period
there is nothing concerning happening in
arkansas as far as the election goes
it's an extremely red state and sarah
huckabee sanders will probably win but
in some other places that are slightly
less red red but slightly less red we've
already seen democrats win and they
immediately say that there's fraud there
is no evidence of fraud it's that we do
have a unique situation where many
americans are completely sick and tired
of these republican nuts
you have many americans who are seeing
roe v wade
nothing done on gun safety
nothing presented as far as policy just
attacking democrats attacking liberals
on and on and on and they're sick enough
of it that independents primarily but
some republicans are choosing to vote
for democrats and turning out in greater
numbers and so we've seen some
relatively surprising democratic wins
early so far and we will see what
happens in november
it's not even a question they're going
to do the voter fraud routine again it's
there's not not even a doubt sarah palin
has already done it in alaska kerry lake
did it in arizona um
interestingly
nobody's saying there was fraud where
liz cheney lost her primary in wyoming
very interesting i wonder why that is
incredible with years of fraud in every
race
suddenly the wyoming primary for liz
cheney was totally clean well what can
you do must be some explanation for that
but they're going to keep doing this
and it's it's totally plausible it will
again lead to violence at some point in
the future horrible stuff and they do it
so casually it's very anti-american
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
david
patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show we're going to take a quick tour
through sort of a new level of depravity
for radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene and she's as
disgusting as she is hypocritical
remember all of marjorie taylor green's
my hipaa stuff where somebody would ask
her hey
are you vaccinated and she would go well
that's my hipaa and of course it wasn't
hipaa relates to the transmission of
medical data by medical professionals
and providers and insurance companies
and associated organizations if a
reporter goes hey
are you vaccinated it doesn't violate
hipaa but
uh we now have marjorie taylor green
sharing the medical information of a
child now we're going to look at an
article from lgbtq nation there's
nothing
really concerning in what i'm going to
show you uh but there are like sort of
very mild medical pictures that are
going to come up as part of what
marjorie taylor green tweeted just as a
heads up
marjorie taylor green shares child's
medical photos in bizarre anti-trans
rant it's not clear the congresswoman
even knows what the photos show
but she's sure they show a minor and she
shared the pictures anyway
okay
marjorie taylor green shared pictures of
one or more miners on twitter in order
to attack the family of a possibly
transgender young person
this child is not old enough to vote buy
cigarettes or watch an r-rated movie but
they let her choose to have them cut her
breast off
she wrote while sharing a tweet with two
pictures
one of the pictures shows a girl in her
early teens fully dressed
the other shows a young person in their
late teens or early 20s shirtless after
what happens what appears to be a double
mastectomy
my protect children's innocence act will
stop this she wrote referring to a bill
she introduced last month
green retweeted anti-trans activist
chloe cole who wrote real reality check
nothing is okay about this okay so the
pictures are here okay there's there's
really nothing there's almost nothing
that we can see here um on the left
again it's a picture of
what appears to be a young woman and
then on the right you can't even really
tell if it's the same person you you
can't really tell anything about it
there's someone with with band-aids over
their nipples
and um
there's a scar and there could have been
a double mastectomy there it we don't
even really know who this is or what it
is but marjorie taylor green's belief
is that it's all the same person and
that at least in some of these pictures
maybe all this individual is a minor now
what's called gender affirming surgery
is not performed on minors rights lgbtq
nation in fact the off-repeated claim
was rated false by politifact
nevertheless the idea that children's
hospitals are performing gender
affirming surgeries on young children
has gained traction on the far right
leading to harassment and death threats
against pediatricians okay i don't even
care about that part because we've
covered that part before
this is not a hipaa issue what marjorie
taylor green did here is not a hipaa
issue hipaa relates to medical
professionals and related organizations
sharing information about patients
but if marjorie taylor green is
concerned with medical privacy
to the point where when she's asked by a
journalist
are you vaccinated she goes that's my
hipaa you don't get to ask me that
then she really should care about this
this should be wrong based on her own
apparent moral compass
there is no such thing as a low
below which this woman will not stoop
she's a horrible person
i hope that there are consequences for
this
these people offer nothing substantive
and as we talked about earlier in the
show
when lauren bober
during her debate against her opponent
in colorado
mentioned nancy pelosi's con job a dozen
times
part of it is
that stuff works to some degree with
their electorate because their
electorate is so weaponized the other
part of it is
uh they don't actually have anything
substantive to offer marjorie taylor
green doesn't offer any policy and um
this is what you get when you put these
people in power retweeting pictures
of individuals she believes are minors
we don't know that they're minors we
don't know the origins of the picture we
really don't know anything but she
believes that at least in in one of
those pictures that individual is a
minor if it's even the same person in
both pictures and she still is
retweeting and amplifying it it's
absolutely horrifying
hey here's very interesting news
the next alex jones defamation trial is
starting now i know many of you are
probably thinking david we we just had
the defamation trial
what do you mean alex jones there was a
judgment against him for 50 million you
interviewed me i interviewed the
attorney mark bankston well remember
mark bankston told us that was only the
first of many trials and the associated
press is now reporting trial set to
begin for alex jones in sandy hook case
a month after losing one nearly 50
million dollar verdict
conspiracy theorist alex jones is set to
go on trial a second time for calling
the sandy hook elementary school
shooting a hoax and causing several of
the victims families emotional and
psychological harm
a six-member jury with several
alternates in connecticut will begin
hearing evidence tuesday on how much
joan should pay the families since he
already has been found liable for
damages to them the trial is expected to
last about four weeks
last month a texas jury ordered jones to
pay 49.3 million to the parents of
six-year-old jesse lewis one of 26
students and teachers killed in the 2012
shooting in newtown connecticut jones
lawyers
uh jones lawyer said an appeal is
planned this is going to get really bad
this could be the end of alex jones and
infowars and i have to tell you the
world would be better off if that were
the case the connecticut case has the
potential for an even larger award than
the 50 million because it involves three
lawsuits which have been consolidated
that were filed by 15 plaintiffs
including the relatives of nine of the
victims and a former fbi agent who
responded to the shooting this is going
to be a really big deal and the best and
most
fair if we want to talk about justice
the most just thing that can happen here
is for alex jones to have to pay
uh all of these victims for what he did
and uh this may end infowars that's true
uh at the same time
alex jones immediately started
fundraising on the last verdict and
roger stone recorded videos supporting
alex jones fundraising on that verdict
and um
it's not clear
that this is it for his followers it
actually may be
motivating his followers from from just
little spits and spurts that i've been
seeing on twitter and elsewhere
some of the infowars audience is quite
motivated to donate and to buy
whatever stuff alex jones is selling on
the basis of what they believe is a
completely unfair verdict so i don't
think it is obvious yet that this is the
end for alex jones and infowars but mark
bankston uh the lawyer the plaintiff's
lawyer who we interviewed not long ago
he told me i probably don't have a
definite remember alex jones has
attacked me i don't know how many of you
guys remember that thank your lucky
stars every day you're not dave pacman
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad pacman's a loser
yeah unfortunately that according to
mark bankston does not raise my case to
the point of defamation but
this is probably going to clean out alex
jones even if there are
comparatively smaller verdicts there are
so many plaintiffs in this next case
this could be the end and we will be
covering it and we will see what happens
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is a caller
who uses very disgusting language some
of which we've had to clean up for our
broadcast version of the show
uh but he also is making a point that is
just wrong that i disagree with let's oh
just lost my microphone oh my goodness
did you guys see that that was crazy i
literally just lost my microphone let's
see if i can get it plugged back in
okay there i don't think that's ever
happened on the show before uh okay that
will probably be memed we're
uh let's listen to the voicemail
hey david i just want to know why you uh
prefer to gargle joe's hiding up
that's a technical term the gargling of
nuts on a regular basis
like i prefer the i prefer the young
kirk
because they're at least willing to
admit
that he is a failure of a president
right he's a joke
he does nothing yeah i've not seen that
episode of tyt you you sit back waiting
for headlines
that make jokes by and look good in your
own eyes
you know you know something you'll suck
his nut
the entire segment that's what you do
so
are you funded by the democratic party
in any capacity or
are you just that much of a show
for the democratic party i don't
understand
i thought you were smart initially but
oh
now i'm starting to doubt my initial
assessment
come on man come on man all right so
let's go through it point by point joe
biden is uh basically 20 months into his
presidency for the first 17 of those 20
months when joe biden had an
accomplishment i would tell you that he
had an accomplishment and my growing
sense was this presidency was not going
well uh the approval rating or lack
thereof reflected that um there was uh
there were long periods without any
major legislative accomplishments there
were um a number of different um events
that took place for biden that were not
useful to him and i called out all of it
and yes in the last three of his
20-month presidency
there is new life in joe biden's
presidency a number of important
legislative accomplishments um
a number of good economic factors that
only relate a little bit to joe biden
remember as as as i always have when we
see something happen in the economy that
doesn't really have anything to do with
the president i gladly tell you that and
i mentioned it still helps the president
when good things happen in the economy
so
i think that like many callers one of
two things may be going on one
they see one of my clips in a vacuum
where i pray something joe biden did and
their takeaway is that i am
gargling
joe biden's let's use a more polite term
apple bags okay that i'm gargling the
apple bags
uh sucking up to joe biden i guess the
phrase would be
because they don't see my other clips
and they haven't been paying attention
to the show long and that's one
possibility other possibility is these
people
just don't care and they just want to
make these allegations
and um the third possibility is that
they meant to call a different show that
often will happen i will sometimes get
people who call in they go david
that thing you said about
uh you know someone i've never even
talked about that was absolutely
horrible i'm unsubscribing i don't think
you were even subscribed to me because i
don't even know what you're talking
about so any of these possibilities are
um uh on the table
but
i have been very critical of the biden
administration
the last three months have been
significantly better for him
and many indicators looking better and
better economically in the united states
that's the reality we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today it turns out
that the incoming king charles iii
after the death of queen elizabeth ii
king charles will not have to pay
inheritance tax on the queen's private
estate which is worth more than 750
million dollars
that's a great deal if you can get it so
we'll talk about what is normally the
inheritance tax in the uk
and how it is that king charles avoids
that we are going to talk about nigeria
becoming the first country to ban
foreign models and television ads
television ads airing in nigeria will
have to have models actors maybe you we
would call them who are nigerian and
we'll talk about why they're doing it
how you enforce such a rule and more and
lastly we are seeing more and more
companies drop vaccine mandates for
covet
the most interesting thing to me about
this
is that for years we were hearing from
the anti-vaccine right
the vaccine mandates at work are just
the first step
in
whatever some dystopian authoritarian
slippery slope of tyranny
and we the reasonable people knew all
along that's not going to happen that's
not at all what this is this is just
vaccine mandates for when it makes sense
and then it's all going to kind of fade
away and that's exactly what happening
and those people are completely silent
at this point in time all of those
stories
and more we will talk about on today's
bonus show when i'm joined by producer
pat ford you can sign up at
joinpackman.com couple other things to
tell you about uh we will be doing a a
huge membership special
on 9 19 that's next monday monday
september 19th it will be 9 19 themed if
you would like to take advantage of this
great membership special all you need to
do is get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and then on the morning of 9 19 you will
get an email telling you exactly how to
sign up for a discounted membership all
right
don't miss it it's a doozy my accountant
is saying david don't do it
my business manager is saying david no
our lawyer is saying is this discount
even legal it's so huge
and i am saying we're doing it
we are doing it for the people and so uh
i look forward to seeing you on the
bonus show either today or after you get
that discount
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below